hello lovely people Everyone welcome to
my channel and today we are playing
pentiment which is a new and very very
very unique looking game
from obsidian um which is currently one
of my favorite Studios on the planet
um
this game is or has been really excited
me since we first saw it announced which
was actually just earlier this year I
was so confused about what it was
but uh Having learned a little bit more
about it during the preview period at
Gamescom I'm all in I'm super excited so
we're just starting at the very
beginning of the game here
and what the purpose of this is to rub
that out maybe
press Stone ah
[Music]
do people used to erase things with
stones did that used to be a thing
and I know they did a lot of really cool
stuff with the text specifically to make
it look like actual traditional ink in a
very very cool way
at least in my opinion
and I believe this is it's basically
like
an adventure game
um
I think I'm out of Mystery
it's 2D very specific art style
significant to the era
[Music]
I'm really excited to play it it looks
so unique
very much looking forward to it and also
um the episode of my video game writing
one-on-one podcast this month will be
with
Josh who I believe is the director
[Music]
so if you want to ask any questions for
Josh you can leave them up on patreon
[Music]
this is already very pretty
[Music]
there you go narrative director
Josh Josh Sawyer
he was also just the director
15 18 huh okay Holy Roman Empire
you know when I was um
when we previewed the game they
definitely made it
sound like a very religious Society
[Music]
is he dreaming right now is this dream
then
and the Abbott said to me Andreas
and what are you distracting the sisters
in the library I need you to finish this
commission by the end of April keep a
conversation with brother Piero to a
minimum
up to the devil's work again are you
[Music]
Devotion to one's work can yield
pleasures of the Mind superlative to
those of the body
all right you need to spend time with
more exciting lovers or I need to learn
how to whip the Socrates way
here how do you reply to the Abbott
interest
s apologize and said I'd be more mindful
I said it's not my fault that God made
me this handsome I ignored him
which is what the common merited
[Music]
it takes great fortitude to oh that's
literally Socrates I didn't read that
that was his name okay that's cool we're
starting in in hot and heavy here
it takes great fortitude to be attentive
to yourself and your work
especially when there are pretty numbs
around
to make everything perverse
yes
it is virtuous to focus on your work
with the Abbott cannot hold you
responsible for the feelings of the
sisters
despite the Abbott's eye you must endure
soon you will have finished both the
Abbott's work as well as your
masterpiece and then you will return to
Nuremberg where marriage and your new
life as a master away
yes marriage is someone he's never met
hardly ideal I want her relationship to
me is them
well the alternative is becoming a
philosopher
oh Jesus then you should definitely get
married is she pretty at least
that's what my brother said in his
letter but maybe he's trying to lick my
spirits small portrait they sent was
lovely but we honest can be flatterers
oh who knows
it is growing late The Wheel of Time
stops a no man Andreas I feel you must
leave us oh true
will he visit us again soon so I'm an
artist for the palace I suppose
um hopefully but it's out of my control
your majesty I don't know your majesty
well I can't always dream of this place
there are so many things trust in
Providence
subscribing please see Andrea safely
home
of course your majesty yeah again I
wonder if this is supposed to be a dream
beautiful
[Music]
big fan of this guy down the bottom
poking his tongue out he's a cutie
[Music]
at least I would if they'd stop stepping
on my feet
watch where you're going that's a lot of
gestures for one boat that is
quite a right
[Music]
therefore's Andreas no point in trying
to teach them anything
[Music]
I know well John wants you to enjoy the
Abbott's [ __ ] but since I take you home
I get the last one don't let him run you
ragged boy I want the Abbott come push
me around he's just trying to keep order
in the Abbey I'm an outsider it will be
fine I don't want to cause any trouble
that's no way to think about it you need
to stand up to yourself
[Music]
to research goes into
making something like this is
historically accurate as possible I feel
like it must be
pretty significant
would you please
[Music]
I give up take me home
As You Wish Andreas
he's a hehe guy I know a couple of he he
guys people who type he he too often
good morning Ursula
you couldn't even see her go
um Andrew and I that's really cute
the font being improper to suggest that
a child can't
articulate
the syllables that well is a really good
idea
time to get up as we all say when we
wake up in the morning
one the baron April 15 18. okay a few
more pages back to The Abbey quests
we should clean this up
the pickatrix key of Solomon the hip
demeron prior phrenic it's giving me all
these books to read
you don't need to go to bed right now
let's go over the quest Joey
this is cool uh Prime hour six another
day another few pages for the Abbott and
hopefully a few for myself I need to get
across town and head up the Abbey so I
can start work at the scriptorium okay I
thought I was an artist
oh
that's cool cool scene transition hello
it's really cute
Laura
good morning Andreas did you sleep well
quite well actually thank you ordinary
as far as sleeping goes not well but
there's nothing to be done about it now
ordinary
well as long as you didn't sleep poorly
oh
the way that like the O's are different
the text looked like it text looks like
the Inca spilled differently
there's not that much repetition of
shapes either the L's look different I
mean those two D's are obviously
identical
like a such a cool unnecessary extra
detail
anyway I know you'll be off to The Abbey
so I packed you some food
almonds cheese and some of the Rye you
like from albums
what I wanted me to ask you to join in
for dinner at The Abbey
okay how do I stopped by
yes around Dawn
also the way that their clothing looks
like watercolored ink stained too is
really neat here you are Andreas
that's too kind of you Clara many things
Master Andreas if it wouldn't be too
much trouble could I I mean could we
what you trying to do I don't know if
it's too much trouble yet
would it be too much trouble to pay next
month's rent today hmm
and if we raised it by two grossian
I hate to ask that we're behind on our
taxes to The Abbey two months behind
we live in a society you know what I'm
saying
Peter's losing his hair a bit even more
than usual I mean
of course it's no problem at all
besides you wouldn't want people to lose
any more of his precious I suppose it's
not out of the question not promise
anything I'll see what I can do
oh I hmm
I'm gonna go with I can't promise
anything I'll see what I can do
of course I understand I hate to even
ask of you because when somebody raises
your rent you don't go oh yeah no don't
worry dude I got you you go uh don't I'm
gonna have to budget for that don't I
also have taxes to pay to The Abbey
because we really do live in a society
our taxes get harder to pay every year
and Peter works hard but it just never
seems like it's enough can relate I
still haven't paid my taxes this year
yet
Saint Luke bless you for helping us out
speaking of St Luke how was your
Masterpiece coming along it's been two
months now hasn't it
slowly I'm afraid most of my days are
spent doing work for the app
it's only during the Divine Office that
Kraft
baroque
oh oh
oh very nice you got rid of the one and
fixed it all right
Pariah Frank whose name I think we've
seen before allows me to work for my
masterpiece a reasonable restriction of
its logo
the city council doesn't require it to
become a master I'm making it mostly to
show clients and for my own sake the
sound of the pen scratching is so
soothing to me
it's almost like
like it's gonna put me to sleep just
hearing this the oh beautiful
hand on parchment sound
hope that would help get the hair out of
my face but it actually just made it
worse
stupid hair
that looks terrible but he's more
manageable
um and yes when I do finish I will go
back to Nuremberg where Mary and open a
workshop of my own
from Nuremberg to University and now
traveling the wild is an artist
what a life you haven't had of you
master Rodriguez so I wonder if every
character has their own
but that seems like that would be a
massive and very difficult undertaking
but very cool for expression of
character in a game where they aren't
voiced and um
character models
aren't likely to be massively different
yes I suppose it does feel like I'm
starting a new chapter in my life after
a few more steps are wandering a little
too much fun
so I'm wondering
it must be rather frightening starting
all over again
I owe it to my family to make something
in my life it is but I know now that
this is what I must want to do I really
like that that's so cool
they helped me even after I dropped out
of University oh this will be remembered
oh okay I've chosen a motivation for
what I'm for what I'm doing which is I
owe it to my family to make something of
my life but she's not surprising that I
gave that answer my family's super
important to me I didn't even really
think about it but
that is certainly a thing I'm sure you
make your family proud of Trace
anyway I don't know anything about art
but I've seen you sketching such
beautiful things in your little book
the Masterpiece must be wonderful
it is it's my finest work it's getting
there it's hard to say until it's done
can relate to that too
that's no way to think about it I'm sure
it will be a treasure when it's finished
now I have to get back to my own work
have a good day at the Abbey Andreas and
we'll see you after this supper
not tonight but thank you Klaus Draka
invited me over for supper
of course please hello say hello to the
truckers box
until later Clark
gonna talk to Eva
are you trying to get married because
you're sort of hot
oh uh it's as far as I can go that way I
expected the door to be there other I
see the doors that way
look this out okay nothing
out we go
I like this world a lot I do want to
talk to everybody though which could
make this game take such a long time
let's talk to Peter
oh he just said hi
ill Peter wait is that two peas one of
them's ill God bless you ah
Andreas
uh oh yes Andreas
this weather's been
how do I did that
God awful this town's gone to [ __ ] since
my days
things very different when you were
young
as different as beer and piss
the old Abbott didn't bother us as much
about our customers
I mean it's it's introduced conflict
very quickly right like this game's done
a very fast job of saying
your the taxes in this town are an issue
you work in a really specific setting
a lot of hearing a noise and I realize
it's my dog scratching
um
there's conflict there where you're
being controlled and that your life is
set up for you to leave like that's
that's a very fast setup of
numerous uh threads
he didn't mind if we left a little
offering to perched her to keep the
skies clear the weather Fair
oh I forgot this game has a glossary
so it'll give you
maybe if I use it right now
uh Matthias knew that something Christ
why is the all the god stuff late for
this guy specifically I wonder uh Christ
was in our hearts even if the white
lady's name was on our lips
the church band all observances of pagan
Goods El Peta what sort of all Customs
they thought Saint Morris was protecting
tassing you think the spirits have been
fouling the weather since nobody's
Customs anymore hmm
yes and Saint Sasha II
but who do you think protected it before
they came on us
the Saints weren't the first to watch
over tassing my father knew that old
running Kempo knew that
busted out but may not like it but some
of us keep the Traditions alive
I won't mention that at the Abbey
what are these Traditions entail when
you got up in the night to take a piss
go around the right side of the house
and never go back the same way okay
that way the witches don't steal your
soul
oh how interesting
I should go
all right God bless you thanks man
appreciate that do I want to go this way
looks like a car okay
I can't talk to whoever that hottie is
oh
big jog morning Andreas morning big jog
how's it going you working today
just taking over rest for a bit dad's
still in the field
he hit a big rock with the plow and it
took me God knows how long Lord damn it
how long to pull it out you off to The
Abbey
every day but Sunday
right thank God for Sundays
smells like a storm's coming no
huh just smells like fresh I'll find out
I mean what a smell what a smell
you've been traveling too much
where was it you spent your wondershare
before you came to tassing
ah background pick a background that
will affect your character's choices
going forward person holding in front
basil Andreas knows some Italian and
French and can reference cultural
touchstones from basil and nearby burn
Zurich and aerberg Flanders Andreas
knows some Dutch in French and can
reference cultural touchstones from
Antwerp Bruges and gent Italy Andreas
knows Italian a little greek and can
reference cultural touchdowns from
Florence Spanish and Milan I'd go basil
because
that's more interesting to me
but
I think that given the era of Florence
Venice and Milan are probably the ones
that I will understand
the best so we're gonna go Italy
Italy Florence for a while but Venice
and Milan as well I was also in Italy
for the first time
a few weeks ago I went to Rome
Italy you know one of your senses are
dull you've been there you've been down
there too long
spend enough time in these mountains
it's gonna occur these
yeah very cool and you'll be able to
smell a storm coming
how long will that take
um 10 15 years oh you can totally smell
a storm coming I can totally do that
I don't think I have that long big joke
why did you spend all that time in Italy
doing anyway
other than art I mean
okay background that will affect your
character's choices going forward hypnos
Andreas seeks out pleasure wherever he
goes he's extremely social and quite
experienced in all of the enjoyable
vices of the world definitely not
Andres lives to work and dedicates all
of his time to Art that's the Craftsman
that's probably me Bookworm Andrea
spends all of his non-working free time
finding and reading as many books as he
possibly can I like that for the era
rap scallion
Andreas has a penchant for getting
involved in Petty schemes pranks minor
crimes and fist fights and business
managers devotes much of his time to
sell promotion optimizing business
expenses making Investments and
balancing books I'm gonna pick whichever
one I think is most interesting for this
game
it's not Bookworm because that's
basically what he does at work
I'm gonna go with rope scallion I think
that that seems like it might open up
the most interesting stuff
getting into trouble I got involved in a
scheme or two a bit of Mischief more
than a few roles street fighting is sort
of a pastime on the Italian peninsula
just for fun really
I wonder how long it takes to finish
this game so you can see what the
changes are across the
various backgrounds
sounds like a strange way to pass the
time Andreas anyway I have to get going
maybe I should just move my webcam
up here seems good
cool okay
dad's already acting like I'm taking too
long even though I did all the work to
get that rock out
see you later Andreas until later
all right time comments let's go
talk to Anders hello Andres blue
loving all the Sheep
so right I come button please can you
give me a hand here
what do you want I'm keeping an eye on
them
[Music]
that looks a lot like
to change my webcam again
real small now
that looks a lot like standing there and
doing nothing
for Christ's sake help your cousin ah
morning Andreas excuse us the fence rail
spell and she started hopping it
is something I can do to help excuse me
I'll try to stay out of your way mutton
you idiot are you going
should I offer to help
the strange menu
oh you can like consult
perhaps helping out this also helps us
it allows us to feel useful and take
satisfaction it'll work that idiot
Martin should be helping them yell at
him give him a good scare hmm
well let's hope that again I don't know
anything about sheep and I probably just
get in their way
how often I help why not have you ever
handled sheep before
no ma'am
then over thank you I was curious what
gameplay that would give me like this
doesn't seem like the kind of game where
it's gonna have a help sheep minigame
right I don't I don't know that there
are going to be many mechanics Beyond
talking there's got to be more than
than just that but um
my curiosity was is there really going
to be a sheep wrangling mini game that
seems pretty unlikely so smart way to
get out of it give you the idea of
choice but not actually
oh look there's something going on up at
steinout's place
who's that on the horse looks rich
I don't know Martin but lookney is
giving him an earful
I haven't seen lucky that worked up
since Peter and Clara's wedding when you
hadn't pulled his pants down
not two of my Ma's teeth out you don't
want to feel the strength behind a stone
make some zanga
you think he's a noble he looks really
rich
damn it Martin stay out of trouble for
once
what on hoodie
behave yourself don't we have enough to
deal with right now
Andreas if you wouldn't mind moving your
skinny little body up the road we need
to get these sheets under control
apologies ma'am of course see you later
uh good luck
I'm just gonna keep moving
I didn't want to go that way I wanted to
go this way okay I wasn't sure if I
could even do that church and Dragons
the sheep sounds
ooh warning Andreas How is how's it
going
I wonder why he's doing that
morning class another day at the Abbey
another few hours to work on my
masterpiece good to hear you still
coming by for supper tonight oh this is
that guy who invited me over for dinner
I have a friend look at me go
um Marie and Bert would love to see you
you really need to see these new
woodcuts I have for an Italian edition
of till and Spiegel that's also really
pretty the the um
being
different intensities
I just noticed the animation in the
background of the people doing the field
work
they're lovely I didn't realize father
Thomas let you print books in Italian
come on Andreas he's not that strict
I know he's just trying to protect
people from I didn't say witch Mania
Adventures adventure stories of
questionable real sloppy type setting
I'm gonna go heresy
sure why not some of the things people
are publishing these days would make
Bishop's head spin or an abbots
yeah it doesn't take much with that one
I know but at least you at least I don't
have to deal with him much
so supper tonight after Vespas
of course thank you
great I'll tell Marie about you're
coming see you then
see you later
a Drucker house huh
Thomas God bless Master mailer I hope
your week is going well thank you Father
it's going quite well I'm just out on my
way up the hill to get to work or thank
you Father but I'm running late to the
Avenue
oh he looks really cute
the cute father gob is he just wearing
socks though we gotta get you some shoes
sir uh Thomas good good Andreas I don't
recall seeing you Sunday morning Mass
you understand how important it is for
your salvation that you receive Holy
Communion don't you
yes I apologize father I promise I'll
make it this Sunday I do but I've been
working on sketches late at night and I
just stayed up too late on Saturday I
don't want to get into an argument with
this practice
okay
going to church on Sunday be such a
burden if not for his sake considered
for your own
this is really interesting so so I
dreamed of these people right I don't
actually know Socrates
um is what I'm assuming at least and
that I'm Consulting
like versions of them in my head or
something
Maybe
it's also can't make you go to mass to
hell with him a man is many duties
father Thomas would appreciate how odd
you are
[Music]
very nice
right there's no need to argue I should
make a better effort to get to Sunday
mass I think those are all in my head
I apologize
you don't have to make a promise to me
but our Salvation is contingent on the
the rich horse guys
oh my what a blessed day to receive such
an illustrious visitor
Mazda Mela this is a Lorenz Baron of a
rough logo
I think that's what that says rough
vocal a great Lord from the countryside
near worms
Lorenz said good to see you father
Thomas it is nice to be remembered
fondly I only wish
all of your neighbors were as welcoming
well yes
what brings you back to our little town
I love that
I wonder if that is supposed to be
that's what they actually said and then
it's updating it for me so he would have
actually said the phrase litty and
that's how I should have read that for
that character but then it's like
translating it to Modern for me my wife
and I were returning from a trip to
Venice we spent a few days in Innsbruck
it was terribly dull
I mean it has certain charm common to
these Alpine Alpine cities but the place
was cramling with Nobles for the
emperor's diet
the emperor was he there did you see him
oh briefly but he was sitting for a
portrait of time quite lovely I didn't
want to bother him or the painter
who was the artist my Lord why was the
diet of my Lord how was that as my Lord
I lived there only a few years ago
let's do it
oh fascinating well the cities
choose
Jews now live in their own quarter in
the north I think that's what that says
the city's artist s still producing
wonderful work
tinian in particular is a God no offense
father
of course
anyway my wife wanted to say to stay a
bit longer in Innsbruck and I decided to
ride ahead to make a visit to creasa I
heard father Matthias died shortly after
my last visit of course
a great loss for the Abbey and for us
all
indeed by Good Fortune I recently came
across a copy of the Historia task test
test VA test VA he was reading during my
last visit definitely some of the font
is challenging but I believe you can
change it in the
um menu they were very careful about
accessibility which is always awesome uh
father Matthias was hoping to find a
second copy to corroborate the contents
of the first
it contains some fascinating details
about the history of this place I'm
afraid they might even cause a bit of a
scandal
uh yes
but I must be off there will be time
enough to discuss
things past items not sure testing
testing I commissioned a manuscript from
The Abbey through father Garnett and I
have come to check on its progress
oh my Lord if you've come to see your
manuscript you should speak with a young
Master mayor here
not quite a true Master yet I still have
to marry and be pre-player city council
so in order to meet you my Lord
Andreas is a journeyman artist from
Nuremberg for the next few months he's
also helped me with the Audi scriptorium
a newenberger artist working in an
average scriptorium in 1518 oh we should
talk Andreas I must know the story I
wonder why that's unusual of course my
Lord it would be an honor well I'm
already late to The Abbey but
I suppose it's all right uh b y I don't
know why that was them
surely my Lord would find little
entertainment or companionship with me
um
foreign it's so rare to find someone in
the countryside who knows anything about
art
yikes
thank you for the introduction father
Thomas
come to supper at the Abbey tonight I'm
writing you to the abbots table damn it
I already have dinner plans is oh don't
worry about it father just show up after
Vespas what is he going to do refuse us
excellent we will see you then well now
I have two dinner plans that's that's
actually my nightmare two plans that
happened to me on Sunday I had two sets
of plans at night and I wanted to die
and I only made one of them
uh mid close I'm dismounting right ahead
of us and take a holster to the Abby's
guest house
I'd like to take my time talking with
Master mailer I'll meet you there
once my Lord
so then a journeyman from Nuremberg
forgive me for saying so but you seem a
little odd to not yet be a master are
you unmarried also no I'm not married
but in truth I came to my vacation
vocation or later than my father and
brothers
I was in university for a number of
years at erford
perfect wonderful about the same
University as Martin Luther have you
read his works tremendous mind
he says things about
might get him into trouble but he's a
brave brilliant man
wait you may have even met him did you
you must tell me
uh no he was a few years ahead of me
still as I do is do seem fascinating as
I do so trust me
I agree wholeheartedly I simply must
meet him if I get the chance
I wonder if the good Brothers of the
Abbey have out of him
perhaps they have even or read his list
of 95
95 thesis against the church
father Matthias was not above having a
lively debate I hope father Garner does
not disappoint in that regard
but enough about Luther finale tell me
about your university studies am I on a
date
forgive me Byron but did you attend
University you seem very well educated
let's do the top one
huh no my family is merely wealthy
enough to have provided me with all of
the books and two does a child could
dream of
I love all knowledge from Aristotle and
casero oh yeah to see to faccino and
Erasmus and everyone in between and yet
to come I may have misjudged the baron
it seems to use this worldwide as any
University student
in truth I am simply happy to speak with
another well-educated man
now then did you own your doctorate
in truth I'm simply happy to speak with
another well-educated man now then did
you read it I wanted to do that
no I didn't totally a master's degree I
didn't finish working toward a doctorate
but I didn't finish up I started oh
that's a shame well what was your area
of study
is text changed I wonder why oh okay
what did I study theology Andreas has a
strong understanding of Catholic
theology biblical knowledge canon law
heresies and similar subject Imperial
law Andreas knows the basics fraction
systems of law that govern the various
states of the Holy Roman Empire
medicine Andreas is familiar with the
basics of human biology and medicine and
things let's go Imperial
law I suppose I thought I could practice
in Nuremberg
it's funny because I also made him a um
rap scallion I wonder if the two are at
odds that could be fun
never had much interest in the subject
honestly a bit dull for my tastes
besides the Empire is such a mess of
jurisdictions ovarian law renish law
franconian law nonsense
I'd rather use my money to pay someone
who studied the nonsense than let it
myself
actually Fair
attilio you if I had any faith I would
have prayed you'd never show your face
here again which one of us
curse you Lorenz Roth Vogel crutches
dogs tearing you to pieces would be too
kind of fate
he's just a community's display a
shocking lack of hospitality don't you
think
what was that about
who knows by the time I finish guessing
the old Chrome will probably be dead
well a lot of your early time in
University every student must study the
Trivium and quadrivium yes
did you have a favorite subject
okay
this is all stuff that I definitely
don't know anything about um okay
latinist Andreas has a strong command of
Latin grammar and vocabulary he can also
easily recall centene antique way quoted
words of wisdom from the Roman Republic
and Empire magician
Andreas
instinctively thinks through the
implications of information as he
receives it um
seems like a good one it's Adept at
spatial analysis and can easily perform
complicated calculations in his head
ourato Andreas has excelled in rhetoric
and University he's still he's a skilled
teacher Persuader and public speaker
Oculus Andreas knows a sole endangering
amount of theoretical and practical
knowledge on Alchemy astrology theology
neuromancy or necromancy and various
magical writes and ceremonies heavens
and earth Andreas knows a great deal
about the constellations heavenly bodies
and their movement he's also familiar
with plants and animals from studying
personal experience
hmm
that doesn't seem that helpful one of
these three seems like it'll be
the most helpful in gameplay I mean this
could be too but I feel like that goes
against this character I'm trying to
build so
I'm gonna go look position because I'm
comparing that with the rap scallion
he's a smart
dangerous man who studied law so that he
knows the ins and outs of it logic
geometry geometry and arithmetic
question for an artist was Aristotle's
organ on the foundation of your study
yes the organon for logic and euclids
Euclid's elements for geometry but the
past few centuries availed one yielded
that makes more sense wonderful new text
on logic
Pizza Avalon provided the foundations of
Scholastic philosophy and established
the Primacy of Aristotle's work the
Englishman William ofham gave us the
summer logic arguing nominalism against
platonic realism
and of course Thomas Aquinas gave us
though the tools to employ both faith
and reason in The Pursuit Of Truth All
monks and Friars of course
a great deal of force Aristotle a great
deal of work to force Aristotle to fit
within the church's vision of Truth is
that so wrong
I question that these great men should
have had to wrestle logic into what the
church established by flat and force I
again I don't know what the political
climate was at the time but I do know
that they put a lot of effort into
making sure that this game was um
historically accurate and um
of the time this is really just the best
way to say that so I am assuming that
um this was a period where people were
potentially becoming a little bit less
loyal to the church thing
and prior and your other studies was
there anything else you excelled at okay
latinous oh I can pick the other one so
let's go Arena
yeah persuasion naturally rhetoric
I assume you study the Greeks and Romans
both
Aristotle and kikara kachera I really
don't know how to pronounce that name uh
of course but also Christian thinkers
like Augustine and Thomas Aquarius
true we have less use for public
discourse than Senators did in the Roman
Republic exactly the doctors of the
church went trying to persuade
politicians but to move the Mind towards
Christian truth interesting
still the principles remain the same
invent your arguments then range style
and internalize them before delivering
them to your audience
pointed though I suppose an artist has a
lot of use rhetoric especially in a
place such as this
not true rhetoric is also an art and
like other forms of art it should be
created for the audience and its purpose
it can be practiced as easily in the
streets of Aurora Town as in the carrier
of run
well put
ah there's the Abbey
I have good memories of this place and a
father Matthias I was sad to hear if
it's passing
how did you come to know him how did you
come to know of kyoso at all kyocell
my family even patrons for curse Curacao
for oh I don't know how many generations
some years ago I heard that Kyocera
still had a wonderful library and
artisans
professional artists have taken over
most manuscript production so I was
shocked to find an active scriptorium
here
well there's not much left of it these
days two old men a young scribe and
means who could places any to create art
the artists that remain here are quite
talented a bit all fashioned well qsl is
more than a bit old-fashioned
some of my friends think I'm mad for
commissioning a manuscript from an Abbey
in this day and age
but well my family have been patrons for
Carousel for Generations it seems wrong
to stop now while they're still Talent
here I commissioned a manuscript through
father God on a year ago I thought I
would stop by and check on the progress
wait are you the artist working on it
it's a prayer book for 20 illustrations
I know the work but no I do know the
artist well the venerable brother Pierre
how venerable
he still has his wits and his skills if
that's what concerns you
brother Pierre has an incredible Talent
with color
that I very much look forward to seeing
I just feel like Pleasant little chat
with a man I've never met before you
know as you do in 1518 or whatever it is
of course
May class tend to the horses and the
baggage I'm heading up to the Abbey yes
my Lord
well let's not keep the Habit waiting
any longer
nuns yes uh quite unusual for a
Benedictine house to have monks and nuns
even if they are separated the church
closed most of them centuries ago
but then kyosao is a place out of time
in malt ways than one so all of it still
is what happened 40 minutes now this is
still a lot of World building
um which is extra fun when it's
historically accurate
do you know mother Cecilia she seemed to
recognize you
we are acquainted yes let's leave it at
that nice
what kind of acquainted you talking
about my man
uh you must be father Godot I am
Lawrence Baron of ooh
nice okay yes the baron of rothavogo so
wonderful to have you here again
we actually did meet on your last visit
oh if you say so I'm not so good with
remembering faces
please forgive me my Lord but I wasn't
expecting you for another few days
yes I know but I wrote ahead I just
couldn't wait to see my manuscript I'm
sure it's no trouble
well I yes I mean no it's no trouble did
you want to see it now
oh in a moment I could do with a bit of
a refreshment though may I grab
something from the kitchen
yes yes certainly my Lord I will meet
you there
Andreas I don't know what you were doing
with the baron but I need you in the
scriptorium now
of course father are you gonna get to
work why are you taking this out of me
it's not my problem this is a bad time
to ask for an advance on my payment for
the book of hours
I'm not gonna do that because I said
I'll see well maybe I should
they need my rent early no
you can ask later then get to work rude
but fair
[ __ ] I should have asked him about an
advanced figure on its taxes
maybe I could convince brother Matthew
to pay me early
Full House fails I could liberate some
money from the sacristian I don't want
to steal it
uh we've got to go to the lower Abbey
probably
that's what I want to explore though
explorian
bless you Andreas
how are you
the brothers and sisters are well so am
I so Iowa thank God Andreas have you
spoken to close trucker lately yes quite
recently why
I believe he may be receiving a medical
text
from bologna soon I'm quite interested
in it
Aliano
can you read Italian
oh no Little Italian and my Latin is not
as good as I would like
I was hoping brother Piero could help me
with it if he has the time
I'm sure he will make time he is a
patient teacher
that he is I will see you later Andrews
until then
most of these medicines were made by
August Stein noren with some help from
Sister Gertrude okay I think that's all
there is in here
got it there's a bed
Saint Luke the patron of artists is also
the patron of Healers
I'm just gonna explore everything
the church
no pretty
first time hearing somebody speak
beautiful God bless you Andreas as your
voice recovered from east of mass
I don't know how the ummah changes
I'm not sure oh yes it was a bit of a
strain but a worthy sacrifice well if
the Lord could give us his all on Easter
exactly
have a good day in the scriptorium
have a good day singing
[Music]
it's very nice
Crypt Tower
dormitory I imagine I'll be here
quite a few times based on how many
things there are to see from him God
bless you Andreas
look at him he's so cute how's the
Sacristy today Matthew
the same as yesterday
does my vocation seem silly to you
master mailer
no I was just being friendly then go in
peace friend knowing that the Abbey's
Treasures are secure for another day God
be with you god bother with you uh one
more thing I have a favor to ask you
yes Andreas I was hoping you'd be paid
for the latest manuscript early
[Music]
this isn't part of the agreement you
made with donuts
you'll be paid on completion of each
additional manuscript you eliminate not
before
we have a few pages left for about you
I'll finish them in a few days anyway
can't you make an exception this once
not without good reason this Abby runs
through mutual agreements not haphazard
payments
breaking such contracts would cause
undue trouble not only for cursail but
for testing as well the matter is
pressing brother Matthew For the Love of
another Christian I beg you to make an
exception is that why father Abbott has
increased the taxes I understand let's
do this one
very well do not ask this of me again
Andreas Miller there's that problem
solved
there you are I shall note this with
father gernon and pry it definitely
thank you brother Matthew
God bless you Andreas
all right all right now I've got my
payment I can give Clara the rent early
yeah definitely gonna give it to her
directly come on now
uh
let's look at the map shall we
[Music]
scriptorium I can go through the tower
[Music]
this one I think
curious about the crypto let's go to the
top
oh maybe I can't
that seems incorrect nothing to interact
with your item just a pretty View
back we go
um
so I can go from the Old Bailey
whatever an Old Bailey is
just an outdoor area
I guess
heard so much about Piero
Andreas God bless you so good to see you
good morning brother Piero good to see
you as well
I don't like this weather my bones ache
it means the storm is coming
Big Joe Gardner says if you live here 10
or 15 years you can smell storms coming
brother our dock has been here long
enough that we can only smell him coming
do not forget oh it's a doc brother guy
the fate of the youths who jeered the
age Prophet Alicia outside of Bethel
are you comparing yourself to a prophet
brother Adolf
I am comparing you to an impatient youth
to whom the Lord in his ineffable wisdom
may choose to strike down I do think
this the way this is written
it's probably not super accessible
because there's a lot of references to I
guess history
um
but the characters are very distinct
even if you don't talk to them for very
long they are written very
individually which is really cool
um brother guy please show more respect
to brother adol keeping mean spirited
come yourself further Ado if you're too
sensitive to guys jokes
stay out of that well everyone seems
quite Lively I suppose that means prior
third is not overseeing us today
he was here but then he heard
Lorenz rough fago had arrived and he
hurried out like a little nurse
my rank is so desperate to impress the
Abbott and Nobles like wrath vocal it's
pathetic
feign kindness to Father Abbott and our
prior only to speak about them like this
by their backs it's shameful
oh oh no
Baron Russellville this manuscript
I just realized that he will want to see
his manuscript how silly of me of course
that's why he's visiting
perhaps if you were younger and Foster
you wouldn't need to worry so much about
patrons visits what what's the problem
the baron is just one client he has to
wait like anyone else what's your mother
give you something to worry about
someday you understanding what Pierre is
as a young monk I like that one
anyway what's the problem the baron is
just one client he has to wait like
anyone else I said it anyway
Andreas Byron rothfogle is not like
anyone else he has powerful friends
including Prince Bishop of frosting
phrasing
because I was already out of favor
father Abbott does not want to have to
deal with more attention
Stakes we're getting stakey out here uh
maybe I'm wrong about thinking somebody
dies I don't remember exactly it's like
an absolute blessing of my I don't know
10 plus years covering video games at
this point is that I will forget them I
will forget my previews and I will
forget trailers and I will forget
information
and it means that every time that I play
something new it's like fresh from the
get-go which is actually like very
helpful
um well if prior ferric isn't here I'm
going to work on my masterpiece until he
arrives
oh that's right I need to to reference
the indermore manuscript
okay you have to find whatever that is
what do you want Andreas a book the
inner moment manuscript the book of
hours
your hair looks messy today did you get
enough sleep
what do you mean
I mean did you sleep alone oh she likes
me
can I just get the book oh that's all
the way upstairs can't you get by
without it
I'm sorry but I really can't I need to
reference it for my work no why are you
complaining isn't it your job
really my feet hurt and the stairs are
so steep I'm just gonna ask a loom
illuminata yeah for lemonade to get it
sister illuminata
Andreas needs help finding a book and I
don't know where it is
Andres
sister illuminata I'd like to borrow the
indoma manuscript of the book of ours
yes I overheard here please return it
properly
I wonder if this will be a mini game or
something
he looks like he's covered in glue
maybe he is I guess it's paint
it's may I see how your Masterpiece is
coming
of course your opinion is always welcome
it's pretty
yes the composition is lovely there is a
joyful spirit in your arrangement of the
figures
the contrast of colors is also quite
nice rich and Beautiful on their own but
not overpowering the scene
is that all
it's an excellent interpretation of
someone else's work
that's what clients want what do you
want
where are you in this work
you don't know there was room for me in
here that doesn't concern me I want to
do a good job
it is inescapable we all put ourselves
into our work whether we realize it or
not
you're right Piero [ __ ] you're right
what does this painting represent
it's November
in November we show peasants leading the
pigs into the forest
the forage on acorns before this water
Andreas The Peasants here are no longer
allowed to forage acorns in the forest
many great Lords and abbots across the
Empire have forbidden it even father
garnered
differences it may this is the way
November is painted
but it is not the way November is
Moody uh is illusion storytelling but in
their most Sublime form the images
eliminate a path to truth
it's most important to me that my
clients are happy they won't pay me for
truth
yes but with God's grace this book of
ours will outlive us all
what will it say to those who see it in
a future generation centuries beyond our
comprehension someone gaze deep into
your lines and paint to seek deeper
meaning what will they find
but you need not listen to my opinions
they are just the thoughts of one old
monk I really like this conversation
there is no place for the monastics
Victoria anymore in truth this room is a
place out of time
why is that why is Cosell kept it up for
so long
some people some places have a difficult
time letting go of the past I am not
among them
the creation of books of art is no
longer the province of monasteries so be
it more people will be able to write
more will be able to read and in so
doing he brought to truth
don't you think there's a danger in
anyone being able to write anyone up
being able to read anything that's wow
I wonder if there's a record of that
mindset having existed that is a very
interesting concept very uh 1984
actually
think there will always be a place for
artists like you and brother edoc
hey tough one because it's interesting
it's interesting there is danger of
course but printers are already here we
cannot roll back the Wheel of Time
it is left to you and the generations
who follow to be good and responsible
stewards for those yet the rest is in
God's hands
all right
it really seems like you guys could just
get a work from home setup and you'd be
fine is All I'm gonna say this really
feels like a work from home setup would
be just gravy
ah where has the time gone it is already
curse
too much talk I must ask forgiveness for
not honoring the rule until later Andres
until later
I wonder why Andreas is dressed so
differently to the others is it because
he's not
oh my what's going on
hmm
what's going on in here
oh check on it
I can't
curious
Andreas what was that noise oh I'm sorry
sister illuminata I knocked up all the
paint to the floor
but then Friar ferret came in wrote in
one of his books slammed it closed and
left
except such a hurry I don't think he
even noticed me
slamming books Shut all right Frank
should know better than that
some of these manuscripts are quite
delicate
seem to be in a great heart
you think he's on edge to inspiring Roth
Fargo arrived early
which is why books should not be taken
out of the library unless it is
necessary for divine reading or work in
the scriptorium again I'm I love this
that this is like a character who's
literally behind a door that we're only
seeing her eyes
but it's still very much a character
it's a
it's wasted
are you still mad at me for borrowing
The Chronic chronic Lara oh that reminds
me there are a few books I've been
wanting to borrow
no anger is not an appropriate response
for a nun but the fact remains that you
trick me into giving you that book for
no valid reason not valid is it not
valid to want to see the work of one
great Irish scribes
one who wrote Masterworks said even now
Grace libraries at cologne
folder and Mains no it's not not unless
it pertains to your work or the Abbott
permits it now if you'll excuse me
wait what's all this fuss about Lorenz
Volkswagen why is bryopheric so nervous
Lorenz I didn't know you were familiar
enough with the man to use his Christian
name
anyway I haven't dealt with him
personally but the prior and father
Abbott have I only know that he's
purchased a number of our most valuable
manuscripts over the years and he paid
enough to keep the Abbey when he needed
it we needed it sir like what what did
he buy I can't remember you know I have
my own responsibilities to attend to
now about this Andreas if you help me
recover some missing books I'll tell you
what I know about the baron
well I was hoping to work on my
masterpiece of course will help
thank you that's where they go to The
Abbey where should I begin
out there where you and your cohort of
cares carelessly strong books around the
scriptorium I will tell you what books
I'm looking for find them and return
them to me okay so I think we're getting
a bunch of side quests
the first books are two volumes of the
ellenide Eleni reddish covers 14 inches
by 10 inches three inches quick
in spark inches on Nuremberg inches oh I
know the ones that are among Piers
favorites he keeps them by my desk they
are not his to keep
and then I probably just get them right
there's a fair amount of wear on these I
hope you don't mind
those volumes will all even when Piero
started to make the copies how long ago
was that
three years
and the a need I'm still not sure what
that word is it's not one of my favorite
stories but I understand why it appeals
to pierra
Andreas chose his duty to the gods over
his enemies millennials over his lover
Dido
do you think
aeneas's sense of Duty appeals to Pierre
we all have our vocations brother Pierre
takes his more seriously than most of
the others in The Savvy you clearly take
your chosen vacation seriously
Andreas I didn't have a choice in my
vocation a few women do
surely it's not that diet you're right
yes of course is it really that bad
a woman that limiting
she's exaggerating it's fine how would
you know
[Music]
sure she knows her life better than I do
it's interesting
um
I'll say you're right of course
I appreciate that you understand how
limited our roles and our choice is
Trulia
this is a really cute
thing I don't really know how else to
articulate what is happening right now
is endearing even in Stories We Are
maidens to be rescued and went cruel
seduces of men or wise into clones
damn that's still true uh like Dido we
ordinary women are merely tools in the
tales of men we can never be the
protagonists of our own stories
no woman is exempt from man from the
empress to undone it is out locked I
suppose I understand now why you are not
fond of a need
let's find poetry for men
now the books if you please
I wonder what the purpose of this
interaction was
setting the stage mode
next wretched urine this is a printed
copy green cover diamond pattern
I do not have the size in The Ledger but
hopefully that description is enough
another one you're talking about brother
adopt was reading it
so let me just grab it from a dog's desk
which yeah
the beauty of this book truly belies
it's ridiculous content I'm surprised
the Abbey owns a copy
we don't it belongs to a majorisco of
yugamo
you you gonna yugano is that an L or an
e
um it's Venetian Edition that's quite
valuable
he learned it to us five years ago it
was subsequently lost and the Abbott has
received three letters about it I've
certainly seen their brothers enjoying
it
that book is not appropriate reading for
Benedict monks Benedictine months
Benedict Benedictine
a baby who sold to Pirates raised to
Servant then lives a lifehood adventure
wooving princesses and fighting in
tournaments if you've got the best part
in the end Guerin learns he has Royal
Blood the son of a Duke He Reigns his
King and dies for his permit it's not to
love
Benedictine should be dreaming of
reconciliation with our Lord not Lusty
Adventures husky hasty
Lusty
what's the harm I suppose your rights
better shoot it for knaves like me
it's not my place to represent anyone
for reading stories Lisa will you
Andreas
still you must be on God
fantasy leads to Temptation Temptation
Temptation has led to the downfall of
many men and women
sometimes yes but books like this it's
all the same type of fantasy isn't it
to die better than we are born
and what's the problem with that why
shouldn't a peasant dream of being a
king
there is neither
Jew nor Greek no the slave nor free
neither male nor female for all the one
in Jesus Christ deep we may be one in
Christ we are not equal in this world
isn't this the word you should be
concerned with Andreas
but the book Andreas we must return it
or would you like The Habit to receive a
fourth letter
the truth it's unlikely you'd be
considered liable in a very long
I hate to see the brothers disappointed
but I understand
it's not my goal to deprive the brothers
of their Joy but to return all mondea
rusco's property or Amadeo good luck
please
entire the book
there's only one book left then you free
from bondage a dark red cover eight
inches high five inches across two
inches thick
the description should be sufficient
foreign
polite I wonder if I'll do a second play
through this game where I make it a bit
more complicated
no I think about it guys always been
guided about this book like he was
hiding it
very good please bring it here
what is this anyway
oh maybe I should have learned French at
some point
what is this oh so if I knew French
maybe I would uh understand what it is
why are you asking so many questions
just give it to me I don't want to know
what it is also
all right
I haven't asked so many questions I've
asked one question twice
I have good reason to not answer you
yes
Three French Bishops condemned the book
all copies were to be burned
its author shared the same fate what why
no no Andreas it isn't my place to
question the Judgment upon Bishop much
less three
and before you ask no I haven't read it
but I know it contains style in between
love and reason
so the book is dangerous when did the
Bishops condemn it
much
it's super creative it's really cool
very unique 200 years ago what why why
is it still here
because father Matthias love books all
books he didn't want to see it destroyed
sounds Reckless and he was right to do
so books shouldn't be destroyed
that content is a good question
I agree
the holy church does not share your
opinion is the law we must contend with
not your emotions
theme song it is not my place to
question the former rabbit's decision
but when father Godot learned it was in
our possession he wanted it destroyed
how did Father even know the book was
here unless the book be destroyed no one
knows that it's here
yeah
mother Cecilia made a note of it in the
inventory when she was the librarian
must the book be destroyed I'm gonna go
with this one while I refuse to give it
to you if that's what you got let's
destroy it
I do so mother Cecilia and father Godot
well I refuse to give it to you but all
you're going to do is destroy it
yeah keep it
what why not what are you gonna do with
it
I'm not sure I'll keep it safe
give me that book or our deal is forfeit
I won't tell you anything about Baron
rothford consider the sound theological
reasons for allowing this book
I appeal to use the librarian of this
Abbey to not destroy this book I propose
a compromise I'll take the book from The
Abbey far away one of these two
I'll be gone by the time father gonna
ask about it and if you like you can say
I stole it
you doubt he'll make a fuss about me
stealing a book he wouldn't destroyed
Cassandra is feels wrong in my heart
I swear I'll take it far away it's been
out of here for years and besides how
could you have stopped me
sweet
trusting you in this Andreas against my
better judgment don't make me regret
this
is kind of tense it's fun
can I see what he wrote In This Book
still though
um can I say goodbye to her
good day and then end it now then Baron
rothfogle quickly though I need to
finish up here soon he said he buys
books with me every what the hell has he
been visiting you seemed unusually
friendly with me I don't understand it
you mentioned finding a copy of his
story a Tessa he said it had some
scandals details on it
He also mentioned that father Matthias
had a copy and was looking for another
to verify its contest do you know
anything about the book
I've heard of it but I've never read it
and I know little about its contents the
subject is Broad but I believe the book
deals specifically with the Roman
occupation of this island what about
that could have set father Matthias so
much
I can't claim any deep insights into the
former Abbott's mind I understood him to
be virtuous and charitable man sometimes
to a false it's not always best when an
Abbott considers himself a friend to his
brothers instead of their Shepherd
do you prefer father Garnet could
something in the book of lead father
Matthias to a crisis of virtue virtue is
only found in crisis without it although
she's a little more than ideals damn
so perhaps there is Merit in that idea
well I must be off to mass thank you for
your help Andreas
wait how will you get to the church if
you got into the scriptorium I thought
this was the only door into the library
we are standing in the oldest part of
the Abbey and like any old place it has
its share of Secrets good day Andres God
be with you
fair enough
[Music]
that's the bell for sext the brothers
will be sitting down to dinner soon
I should see if Otto is around and still
wants to eat with me
he's working by the guest house below
the Abbey
cool I'm gonna leave it there so um
this is very neat and very creative and
I'm interested but I will also say
um I'm really tired right now and it
definitely is uh it's going to be an
intellectually demanding game and you do
have to pay a lot of attention to what
you're reading pay attention to all the
names I think it's really cool that they
have a glossary so that if you forget
who somebody is you can look it up
um so you'll be reminded of who they are
and what they did basically
um and I suspect that's only going to
get broader and broader of like okay
this person is this way they do this for
a living here's where I saw them lost I
imagine this would be one of those games
it's really hard to pick up and then put
down for a week um so I'll probably try
and play through it really quickly but I
think it's really really cool really
really unique
um
yeah I like the writing a lot the text
is cool
I'm down I'm down huge thank you to
Xbox for giving me a code so that I
could play the game early I'm gonna
publish this the morning that it comes
out
um I believe it's out on it's the 15th
at 11 p.m I think
I'm pretty sure
um in any case I hope you enjoyed this
video I'll see you guys next time bye